los jefes de estado seguramente mientras
nosotros conversamos ya Están almorzando
ya terminó la Cumbre y ellos hablaron
cada uno de los cuatro jefes de estado
de los países miembros hablaron Alberto
Fernández que termina la presidencia pro
tempore y le pasó la presidencia Pro
tempore a Brasil insistió en que hay una
visión crítica de lo que se acordó en
2019 con la Unión Europea más todavía
con una adenda un nuevo documento con
demandas ambientales que presentó la
Unión Europea a principios de este año y
que ha sido centro de atención para los
líderes del mercosur pero también dijo
que el acuerdo representa una
oportunidad a pesar de que cuestionó el
proteccionismo del sector de alimentos
europeos sobre todo porque afecta
especialmente a los países del mercosur
Argentina y Brasil grandes exportadores
de alimentos también Paraguay Luis
Ignacio luna de la selva que toma la
posta de la presidencia Pro tempore dijo
que ningún país resolverá sus problemas
por sí solo también eso es una
referencia Uruguay que que si el bloque
no logra avanzar con acuerdos
comerciales tal vez decida ir por su
cuenta lo lo comentaré en breve Cuando
hable de lo que dijo la calle Power
presidente uruguayo pero digo que Lula
dijo que tienen que preparar el mercosur
una respuesta fuerte y contundente para
estas exigencias ambientales que
presentó la Unión Europea a pesar de que
su intención es avanzar con lograr
cerrar del todo este acuerdo con con el
bloque europeo y poder avanzar en ese
sentido es algo crucial para el
crecimiento del mercosur Luis la calle
Pou como decía dijo que es mucho mejor
ir juntos es textual pero que el
inmovilismo es lo que preocupa a su país
Ellos están interesados en un acuerdo
comercial con China y siente que el
mercosur no Está avanzando dijo queremos
hacerlo juntos Pero textual si no
podemos hacerlo de esa manera vamos a
hacerlo solos Entonces se ve una
atención dentro del mercosur entre
quienes insisten en la unidad no solo
por intereses económicos sino también y
lo dijeron
Alberto Fernández Lula da Silva por
intereses políticos y sociales y quienes
insisten en un en avanzar en los
términos comerciales